To finish solving for x we divide both sides by 3, so x would equal 5. So we
know the x coordinate is 5, but remember we still need to find y. I'm going to
use this first equation to find y. I'm going to plug in or substitute the value
of x, which is 5 into this equation. Negative 2 times 5 is negative 10 and then
I add 10 to both sides of the equation to get y equals negative 1. So this is my
solution to the system. And, of course, if we want to know if we're right, we
can check our solution. We'll plug in x equals 5, and y equals negative 1 into
both equations, and it should work. And when we check the first equation, we get
negative 11 equals negative 11. And when we check the second equation, we get 26
is equal to 26. So, yes, this has to be our solution.